cinematography is one of those jobs that
you have
absolutely heard of but still don't
quite
understand completely but if you wanted
to
this group has the knowledge you seek
in judas and the black messiah sean
bobbitt finds excitement
in responding to what actors do when
they're in a space
in mank eric messenger schmidt loves
predicting the moment of an actor in
news of the world
daryu schwalski loves the nuances that
the environment
brings to a scene in nomad land joshua
james richards
was inspired by allowing people to exist
naturally
within a raw landscape and finally in
the trial of chicago seven
faden papa michael finds a visual
language
to establish a pulse
and the oscar goes to
eric messenschmidt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow um uh
wow uh i wish i could cut this into five
pieces because
it's such an honor to be nominated
amongst all of you
it's an incredible honor
david thank you thank you for uh
creating an environment where we could
do our best work
and uh i got to go home and
feel like i gave it all my all every
night thank you
sion thank you for the endless support
[Music]
eric roth thank you for the guidance
amanda gary what a
privilege and a joy to watch you work
the entire cast thank you for hating
your marks
it mattered um
uh and it's this really belongs to an
extraordinary crew
who i could not do anything without
um brian will
alex dave gary dwayne
danny jerry and all of your team
you uh uh make my job easy
thank you and um thank you to my
beautiful wife nayara who
tolerates this crazy business and uh
helped me get through this movie so
thank you so much
thank you
you